هو كل شيء بدا في
2017 يوم انه كنت عضو في اللجنه
البرلمانيه
حيث تحملت مسؤوليه عضوه في لجنه التحقيق
فيه شبكات التسفير لام التوتر وبما انني
كنت من النواب الذين لا يخشون كشف الحقيقه
قمت
بالاستماعات صلب اللجنه قمنا بالاستماعات
للعديد من الشهادات التي
قدمتها بعض الجمعيات والمنظمات
النقابات الامنيه وغيرها الشهادات التي
تورط فيها 80% من حركه النهضه قياده من
حركه النهضه وقمت بتجميع كل الوثائق التي
قدموها لنا في ذلك الوقت في اللجنه
قمت بمده بكل هذه المعطيات على اساس انه
القضاء العسكري او او قرائم ام انها كانت
ادله وحقائق قدمتها السيده فاطمه
هناك العديد من الوثائق مثل تقارير امنيه
او
بعض الاذن القضائيه للتنصت يعني هناك
وثائق تنصت رسميا هناك
عديد من الجداول التي
فيها اسماء ارهابيين الذين تم ادخالهم
هناك بعض الوثائق الماليه هناك العديد من
الوثائق التي قدمت لنا في اللجنه وتم
امداد رئيس مجلس الامن القومي في ذلك
الوقت الباجي قد سبسب بذلك لكن مراعني انه
بعض
2019 بعد ما توفي الرئيس الراحل الباجي
قيد سمسم السبسي لم نجد اي اثر لاي تتبع
قضائي في هذا الملف ولكن بالعكس
اصبحت تحت هرسله قضائيه من حركه النهضه
ومن بعض المتورطين الذين كشفتهم عندما كنت
نائبه في مجلس النواب
تقدموا بعديد القضايا لمده سنتين من 2019
الى 2021 قضايا بادعاء بالباطل في ملف
التصفير ضد شخص فاتنه مسجل وكنت تحتها
العرس القضائيه لكني لم استسلم
وكنت
اتوجه الى القضاء بكل الوثائق والدعم الذي
الوثيق التي تحصلت عليها في اللجنه ومن
بعض المواطنين اثناء عمله كم في البرلمان
وبذلك تحصلت على عدم سماع الدعوه في كل
القضايا الذين قدموها ضدين يعني كل كل ما
تقدمته بالوثائق الا وتحصلت على عدم سماع
الدواء لان الملف ملف ثقيل جدا وفيه كل
الادله على ما تقدمت